[Music]
in not worth it news depends submitted
by end of the deck on deck excuse me
what the [ __ ] would you turn that win
they move your lip towards the [ __ ]
camera how about that huh you're the one
talking shut the [ __ ] up in burping is
on-brand for you you could just burp oh
come on I'm on brand right now you don't
go to the side yeah what no you should
you know here
Sookie touch it it feels so nice oh my
god dude assistance good work swab
brandy look mo you know I've been using
sloth
yes she actually sold me on it Harris
felt so right it though no is it really
that good it takes me forever to run out
of shampoo no you need to try it it's
[ __ ] awesome
and then I even pay me diseases you know
I'm a man and I use swab men when it's
the deal but then I have no loyalty deal
it's a really cheap brand right so then
I but then I have no loyalty so if it's
not the deal I don't get it again but I
do like it when you complain about your
hair falling out come on but now I got I
get to Costco and I get some pretty good
soap there where do you get Kirkland so
prefer one soap my friend it smells like
oranges did you know you can get a whole
pizza there for kids they're like okay
my husband's born now this is so boring
that's actually aren't you aren't you a
Chinese person they have Chinese food
there you can buy it and they already
made for you thank you I'm gonna slash
your tires later shoutouts to Costco
bene a police chief resigned after it
was revealed he used a fake Twitter
account what's the problem a lot of
racial [ __ ] huh oh we arrest you blacks
system
some people otherwise event he said
nothing like that I guarantee you he did
because you know those cops be
brutalizing my brothers right now
alright David please come back and watch
he's like I look like a state next to
you barn hasn't done much talking cuz
you guys holy [ __ ] [ __ ] tequila and
this cat is struggling to be alive his
heart his heartbeat is like three beats
a minute right now I just wanted to
celebrate this is why Bart is the
biggest sweetie in the room almost all
times I really believe that we drink
even though he knows is killing him
exactly it does this to him but he
wanted to partake in the [ __ ]
celebration that we all had about having
David yeah there's a being sweeter as a
foam oh no he's just no he's a sweetie
he's two feet FOMO - bye you call the
biggest movie in the room and I'm a
little jealous well sweetie alright so
this story here it takes place in
Burlington Vermont is there a code
factory they're legitimate I didn't know
there was a Burlington anything I
thought that was just a Colt factory hey
dick chicken Vermont coming after that
yeah I hate that I knew that I hate that
the Burlington Coat Factory ads worked
on me that well no no there's no coal
factory anymore there's just brilliant
it's just Vermont the state now it's an
actual place actually guys just let you
know if our they're the number one code
exporter though did they do more things
in code they do have a [ __ ] ton of
culture
okay so in less than a day Burlington
Vermont had three top cops what does
that mean yeah so the police chief had
admitted okay so initially he denied it
stick to code all right yeah come on now
right let's talk about coax now guys so
the police chief initially lied about
having a fake Twitter account to heckle
a civilian when a local reporter he
called a local community organizer a
cowardly creature hiding behind an
electron curtain whoa he needs an
anonymous account for his weak-ass and
so on holy [ __ ] it's always like old
people that have to get these Twitter's
to know there's like this recent thing
about old people being upset because
they're being ostracized for being
boomers yeah you wouldn't say that about
a black person or an Asian person it's
like hold on boomer a blacks and Asian
people it was just like I read this
whole list of like what they were making
comparisons to a racial slur yeah it was
the most ridiculous thing everybody
understand how memes work that's like
that cat on CNN who talked about how he
got called Fredo and he said that's a
[ __ ] slur and word equivalent of
Italian I'm like dude you have no
[ __ ] clue what you're talking about
that is amazing that's a racist because
a [ __ ] Godfather
Fredo was the idiot brother and that's
what the joke is the idiot brother in
his family oh I thought he was calling
of a pasta dish
his mother's the governor in New York he
is like a stupid [ __ ] CNN anchor and all
those guys suck every anchor on
television is terrible and so that's all
that's why they call Fredo this is
dumbest but then he took it as as a race
no cuz he just wanted the sympathy yeah
that's it
and that's what most people go for right
like Dutch to Edward of white people he
called me a cracker there is no n-word
acquitted I'm sorry no there's not
yeah so anyway so then that was the
first police chief right so then oh and
then like I said he did lie about it
when a local reporter asked him about it
but then later on he went to the mayor
and came clean about it and let him know
that he did have a faked Twitter account
so then that's what Mayor rat it is a so
that's when the police chief ended up
resigning over that and so his
replacement she came out and said oh
yeah
well I did have a fake facebook account
does that count and so she ended
everyone's just too honest to see it's
like an improv scene look if the
replacement comes in like well I did
have a fate of insta okay nope that's
like that guy wasn't a congressman he
was like hey everybody I did blackface a
couple years back and everyone just
[ __ ] like what do you thought
whatever just everyone's like hey thanks
for coming out about it doesn't get too
slow no give you the full bottle so me
please give it to me I know you're not
very potent right now you don't have a
life insurance policy yes so I guess you
can have the water thank you hasn't
impregnated you yet yeah we need life
insurance and then a pregnancy and then
an insemination I'm good very little bit
really being afraid all over here dude
okay then I can just go to that women's
wing place
and be happy I wasn't prepared for David
to be here childcare services a little
weak oh thank you anyway that's the
other article if I knew I would laugh
this hard because David's coming Howard
about lozenges when you go to Costco
yeah you going to Costco and getting a
lifetime supply of lozenges oh thanks
see one around here you could probably
find one in this [ __ ] mess of office
anyway you know take care of your health
god damn you like aged ten years older
than me right now
like in the past year he's got a Costco
membership and like all sudden he's just
an old person he's mothballs closet full
on crack like when he's gone up the
stairs I could hear his knees we talked
about it on youtube.com slash Nikki No
so what's [ __ ] up is that I can't get
an AARP membership even though I feel
that all but I feel that way comedian
Steve green I needed he deserves it so
anyway we were talking about these uh
these fake accounts here so the
replacement of the police chief which
was the deputy chief and like she she
came out and said that she had a fake
facebook account under the name Lori
Spicer where she would make comments of
bounce and engage with citizens in
discussions of police department policy
and practice so she would defend the
police department yeah why would she met
any of this and so where's the part
where she said the racial slur because I
need that to happen for my insensitive
comment earlier oh just like the old guy
that talked about his black face sounds
really yes so they're saying now that's
this third or like second replacements
third person involved it they are 100
percent positive that he has not
a fake account anywhere on social media
he's like I'm good I'm clean guys
finally live like finally first sports
in LA yeah he's like I'm very sure and I
feel very good about this so the person
that one citizen that he got attacked
the whole thing was from the first one
he said the entire scandal and cover up
cover up is petty shameful and a deeply
disturbing people got fired
what's the cover-up they're just coming
down with this because they did cover it
up for a few months until like he came
out in the end result yeah now they're
saying that there's gonna be an
independent investigation to review the
pub the police department's social media
use and policies well you're gonna do
what they're gonna do that's how silly
this [ __ ] is management isn't like
people that they were being interviewed
on the street like locals they're like
well do you think regular citizens
should be having fake accounts and
they're like well yeah right listen
whatever but then like do you think
public officials should have fake
accounts and they're like no what the
[ __ ] they were held up held up to a
higher standard like if they're trying
to do if they're trying to heckle other
like civilians like just [ __ ] do it
as your own account like you have a
sense of like you have this type of
responsibility over the community like
you should not be doing that period why
are you creating a new you should be
mature enough to yes articulate a point
and defend themselves or whatever
wait now it or girl like they got found
out because they just admitted to it
yeah just kept them secret just
completed another fake account I don't
know how defending my actions MIT Romney
did this [ __ ] MIT Romney got busted
praising himself with a fake Twitter
account be and I go away MIT your
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] funny so
embarrassing he admitted to having a
fake account then people found what it
was instantly you don't have to he
admitted it to a reporter like cheekily
like hey I got a they're like another
can I use it sometimes and they found it
like in [ __ ] people don't know
because he followed himself he's a dumb
[ __ ]
they don't know how social media works
so they just like think it's secret
everything's secret yeah
I just would never admit it and I would
make more accounts it's like and use a
VPN he's like hey you'll never find it I
have a fake account and then you really
just see a gun account that where he
blows himself
[Music]